how do you sleep
I have 16 brothers and when my brother
was playing with me at school it may be
why someone when I got out I socked him
you know like maybe since I'm asleep I'm
born in the ones I was raised in what it
was a hard part of life I've been to
jail I'm being a prison and so dope I'm
grateful I shouted folks I have a big
problem with assaults have seven years
assault case well actually I'm a cheap
so my biggest thing is relationships
hey that's not good for me you know
because I take iris a relationship
seriously you know so I've been to
prison twice for so result the first one
I was close to attempted murder but he
lives over in his assault he got down to
assault
hey I'm shot nervous he's nothing to be
proud of but you're on me age you have
to be you go like this I bet you have
lost 13 years old so when you have to
grow up by the street life and its
survival
I mean there are people who understand
that it's like you can change your
lifestyle but for me a system brother so
I felt like I had no sister to depend on
so I have 16 brothers these two of us is
I'm a queen but my mother was never
around so the boys was always running so
I work with the rough boys
my mother now my mom is Dean Oh at work
all the time this is what you doing
pills and drugs
so I'm raised around truth
peels you know good job oh my dad you
know stuff while you and my dad dad is
in order
my stepfather he was here he worked my
mom tried to sell me to the dopamine and
for drugs my mom sold to told me I was a
would never let my mom house when I was
13 I turned my first trick when I was 14
I was 14 years old and I left it in my
mom and I've been on the streets ever
since I just recently what eight years
ago I had got in a relationship he just
recently died but he knew about my you
know my my past so he we have negative
way you know a space between us you know
in that relationship you know I
appreciate him but my kid's father I
tried to kill him twice I did seven
years behind my kids [ __ ] I cut him a
cut him in front the police ain't even
[ __ ] [ __ ] up I'm serious I didn't
give and that's it was a rough life for
me Jeremy and since I really I wouldn't
try 52 years old to get our ID you know
to get my [ __ ] together I just recently
got into a shelter just I've been older
like I've been to prison twice whimper
possessions and assault on the police
office when I was in prison I have 115
still depending on me in prison you know
I mean serious 115 is weird
I didn't hit the police and I look at
the Talmud says I'm changing my
lifestyle it's not cool it's not good
and I was a lot of people really
shouldn't I have changed people life
where people in got this [ __ ] together
I have a home but I know I'm a part of
this story you know but he said okay no
dope dealer jacker now he ain't even put
me in two or three programs I have to
program beat up people in the program
you know salsa in the program you know I
really a really bad lifestyle you know a
I'm quick with a temper I'm very uh
smart with the mouth you know but it's
it's not cool it's not really cool you
know and I tried some of these young
people out here to tell them hey the
lifestyle that you live it
hey change you while you got a chance
cuz there's nothing out there it's
[ __ ] if they're really new really my
I'm picky - is all I have
I don't recommend Mikey yeah I have not
I have grand kitchen Mikey's my family
a the pen is nothing for my eye they
almost gave me a move on life a life
sentence behind officer that I actually
click but didn't they found out dead
she was pop okay no bully me and I
wasn't gonna go for the [ __ ] you
know I know that somebody's pusher push
your button ready again you know but
other than that I'm more like I can put
up with the [ __ ] look when you
provoking me you know like trying to
[ __ ] me like it hey you know I'm quick
to you know look for a woman I ignore
them because they more than this
mournful to me
but a man I'll go with a me and quicker
than I would a woman because that's all
I was raised to me that's how I got
that's exactly how I got my soul cases
you've never been really to men and
women there's been more man you know I
haven't I have a nephew Johnny that's
got losing fingers behind me I cut his
fingers off God forgive me for that
perfect I don't play it you know so I'm
not allowed to have no kind of weapons
in my pocket I'm not allowed to have a
razor blade in my pocket toenail
clippers with your little walking little
bow thing I'm not allowed
you know I'm not allowed to have no kind
of like chemical that's playing pool in
my in my possession
Hey exactly I'm just finished you know I
feel like this weapon wine I'm not
allowed to have things like that in my
pocket you know I bet if you came in my
pocket because I still use that as a
weapon and to Atari game I learn in the
main streets I was in a bunny hunters I
wasn't great for my sons from the grapes
I was from there you know but chin line
yes I got shot in the mouth I've been
shot I would stay out so actually for a
girl lifestyle like that hey I'm blessed
do you know I mean say hey I'm here to
tell story you know I know life you ask
you smoke crack but I grew to a certain
limit I smoke weed I mostly now try to
drink this know each other you know put
that behind you know life ain't life is
horrible
you know I'm the baby at 18 so I'm the
black sheep
oh I see monkeys often when I'm talking
wonderful I have I have six deaths in
New Orleans and I have three
my youngest is 13 and she saw that in me
but I think I fired because she is who
she calls me so my like that you know I
think I wish I think this I might be
really in prison for life behind her if
I wouldn't hit her and I thought I was
praying that I had quit smoking though
for a minute I click being rowdy I
stopped trying to hurt people I said
like that she is the cause of me
changing my lifestyle I didn't got it
actually I didn't get him [ __ ] about no
publisher who still don't really I don't
like the police you know
so he and me and him we had some crashes
some serious crashes
we're a he tried to hurt me and I didn't
try to kill him and that's why he fear
he you know and then after that I like
got so you know but a lover I really
want to know about prison that's no
place to be
that's my lifestyle of janaki and you
can go get it and come out of prison
hey catch him down to somebody to him
hey these little things you can do them
go to her home and her duper that's
crazy
eight eight that will keep you on high
they say Oh
crazy lady behind me a minute to check a
house that I got because my advice it's
like I would stick we have seen it now
stick I just for some reason I just want
to hurt you me that's not my life so I
go to church now I give him out and I
gave my life to God I still get high but
anything like well [ __ ] I want to quit
everything